hey guys Jeff here from ride gamer what
you're about to see is some clips from
the cross-platform comedy stand-up show
we did at comic-con this year I hope you
enjoy I'll leave you with one last
thought back on world of warcraft
because I know you guys love that
clearly this guy does but I was in the
game doing my female Night Out thing and
I should say I don't think I would play
a female Knight up but I like to do the
dance thing and my female fans kind of
like this Oh keep going anyway some dude
I'm standing around I wasn't doing the
dance of time I minded my own damn
business this dude walks up to me it
just goes dude you're so hot what are
you saying that my only response to like
creepy dude right two seconds later he
writes back I'm not creepy where do you
live so I just ignore him for like five
minutes not knowing what to do but he
keeps like messaging me like hey you
want to group up hey need a help what's
going on finally I write back what my
wife always says to me when she wants to
end the like midday I am conversations
we have all right I've got a dick
they usually shut me down
my clothes yeah because I'll be over
here he writes back nice all caps
exclamation exclamation exclamation nice
right it's not like all right dude it's
game on so I know describing what I look
like
right it's a fictional world I'm like
I'm like a female version of Santa Claus
but to take TT boobs you can take me
like an alpha we can do this reindeer
style and the discussion right no he's
like that what are you coming over my
mom makes really good s'mores and that's
the last time I played World of Warcraft
people thank you so much
jump right man
right you guys this man's past you got
to climb here across platform comedy